[Music]
breaking from Russian tradition
some ukrainians are celebrating
Christmas with the Western World
[Music]
parishes all over the country have been
given the choice to Mark the 25th of
December
a symbol of the solidarity felt since
February
is
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
service and people are still coming in
and out
this year the prayers are charged
combat medic mirosla has come from the
front line he's jotting down the names
of all those he wants the church to pray
for his list is long yep
for those on the front line the
festivities are a much needed break
millions of ukrainians are still
separated because of the war but it's
Christmas time and families all over the
country are coming together to celebrate
so everything
[Music]
Alicia vasilenko's children hadn't seen
their grandparents since the start of
the war
as a parliamentarian she's vulnerable to
assassination and sent her children to
the UK for their safety
her youngest was just eight months old
when they fled it's not just being away
from the infant but my other daughter is
seven my son is nine each one of them
need their mother and all of that is
missing from their life and it's missing
from my life and of course it's leaving
scars it's leaving scars which will
become apparent in in years to come
scars temporarily soothed by Christmas
warmth
this fatigue is what Russia is good at
playing at and we have no right no moral
right not in Ukraine not anywhere else
to get tired of this
a day to rejoice as family
but a bitter reminder of what is still
at stake
Sky News